Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great great. for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect
to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, nor so those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. Since I finished reading Nobody's Child by Virginia Jafray, I've been sitting with something I can't quite shake. Whilst I expected the book to stay with me because of what happened in it, that's not actually what's been on my mind. Instead, I've been noticing what I was drawn to and what I wasn't. And if I'm honest, that doesn't always sit entirely comfortably. Because it's made me question what we're actually trying to understand
when we hear stories like this. And how easily we can end up asking questions like, well, why did she stay? Why didn't she leave? So I thought as a clinical psychologist, we could take a look at some of this together. Hi, welcome along to Psychology Actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, I can't be alone that I enjoy reading books
that are relevant to kind of psychology, mental health, trauma and wellness. Growing up, I'm fairly sure in my late teens, early 20s it was, I was reading books by Dave Peltzer like a child called It, that kind of vibe. So I was intrigued when posthumously Virginia Drafray's book, Nobody's Girl, was published. In case you don't know her name or the name of the book, let me give you a little bit of information. I'm going to be talking about things as facts because there have been legal processes that took place that determined that was the case. So Virginia Roberts Jafray might well ring a bell for you if you think about Andrew Mountbatten Windsor, who was previously Prince Andrew. And it was Virginia or Jenna, as she called herself and is called in the book, who had been trafficked to Prince Andrew at the time.
and I'm sure that now the name rings a bell if it didn't already. So Virginia or Jenna had ended up crossing path with Galane Maxwell and with her partner at the time, Geoffrey Epstein. Now, the book is about trauma, it is about grooming. It is about, you know, sometimes the worst in humanity where people start to not treat each other as if they're humans, as if they're humans, as if they have value for anything other than what they want them for.
And that can be challenging, that can be triggering. I think the first thing to say is that it is a book of two halves. So the first half is about her upbringing and essentially what unfolded, what happened to her. And the second half is about justice and getting everything to lay a little bit flatter and ultimately holding people accountable. And I would like to level with you. As a human and as a psychologist, both parts of me found the first half much more interesting. You know, it's this human desire to learn and to find out information and to kind of,
I like reading magazines like That's Life magazine. I don't know if you guys ever read any real life stories, but I love. like knowing about people's experiences and how they felt at particular times and what mechanisms they might have drawn upon to help them to survive tricky things. I personally was less invested in the justice and also I think less invested in her family that she went on to have afterwards. And that's, you know, it doesn't always sit that easy because, you know, you think you want to be this kind of balanced clinician that's, you know, being a justice warrior. But I am also human. So I would love your thoughts if you've read the book. What did you think about the two halves?
How did they stack up for you? So I think some of the psychological mechanisms going on here is that humans are drawn to intrigue and kind of curiosity and maybe sometimes always drawn to a shock factor, you know, so I'm always thinking about kind of compassion focused theory and the way that our brains are wired and put together. And if you find that angle interesting, please do check out the episodes that I did with Professor Paul Gilbert, where we go into compassion focused therapy in more detail. And I think when we recognise that we've got that more of an interest, you know, our attention is held more by that. We shouldn't shame ourselves for it. We shouldn't judge ourselves for it. we as a species are kind of a survival first species that we need to be paying attention to things that might pose us risk or someone else as well. So it is just the way that our brains are
wired up. I think one of the other things that struck me was how the experience of trauma can kind of force us to reprioritize things that we might not have done had we not experienced them. So what I'm meaning here is that a lot of the time, Virginia or Jenna, was away from her family as she was trying to sort all these legal processes. She was often in different parts of the country from them and, you know, that priority being able to choose that over being with her family in a more present day-to-day capacity. It can't have been easy for her family either, but it did feel like the trauma had forced her to reprioritise the justice over the importance of spending that time with her family. And I think maybe that's the desire to kind of do some meaning making
in our experiences when something awful has happened to us. There can be that sense of something needs to count. You know, this needs to have happened for a reason. There needs to be more emphasis on this, more highlight on this, so that this didn't just, happened to me in vain so that other people can take note and so that important conversations and thoughts happen to make it less likely that this will happen to someone in future so interestingly even this morning as I was on social media I saw that the local police force to me had been doing some what they called stings on hotels and and taking young people into hotels with alcohol.
So the older person was carrying alcohol and the older person would say to the younger person, turn your phone off. And then they were trying to pay in cash and they were trying to book hotel rooms. And this is supposed to set alarm bells ringing for the sign of trafficking or grooming. And actually three, I think, of the five people,
called the police immediately. And obviously it was the police doing the sting anyway, so I'm hoping that was revealed. But there were, I think, two people who did allow this hotel room to be booked. And I think it is the learning from stories like this, from cases that then are hopefully trickling into our own narratives, the narratives of crime prevention agencies and kind of social services that are really getting us to think about, you know, really being more conscious and intentional and that we can be empowered to ask questions. I think as we're working in mental health settings as well, it really can be, you know, we need to give us as permission to ask questions, to not assume that people in front of us are always going to tell the truth and to be
compassionately curious and respectful. And this crops up in physical health settings as well, that we need to be trying to make sure that the clients in front of us are not at risk, but aware that they might not be telling us all of the information because of fear from someone that might hurt them or because they are conflicted or groomed or feel like it's not safe for them to do that. So yeah, like that idea of compassionate curiosity and learning from the stories of others, I think for me feels really powerful. And as a mother, I found it really tricky. When during the second half of the book, she describes losing her youngest child, her daughter for a bit when they were at a wildlife park because she'd just taken her eye off her and she'd wandered off and then I think
she eventually found her playing with wallabies or something. And it really made me think about the evidence that suggests when someone has been abused, they are less likely to be able to keep their own children safe because they might not follow some of the safety precautions that people who have not been abused would have done. And I think that's a really powerful idea as well. So not to shame or blame people, but just to be aware of those mechanisms. And when we're working with people who have been abused, it's actually really important We support them to make optimum decisions that keep themselves and their family safe in future. One of the trickiest aspects is the level of abuse that she experienced from her father
and from one of the neighbours growing up when she was a child. And then actually in her adult life, she reconnected with her father and ultimately with her mum too and really wanted to have. her father know her children and be in her life and that is a hard one to understand and I suspect some of the mechanisms that that kept her in the grooming situation with Maxwell and Epstein are around here as well and we're talking about attachment you know wanting to be part of something wanting to have someone know us and see us and be able to share information about our heritage and we We see this time and time again with people who've had really difficult upbringings.
Sometimes that desire to be part of something really drives the bus and is favouritised and prioritised over being part of nothing and being part of maybe just your own family or you know, making you feel vulnerable, unloved, uncared for, which are obviously some of the deeper early wounds that have been set in motion. And there is the reparenting that often happens when people have experienced. abused, that they want their own children to have a different experience. And so maybe she wanted her children to have a different experience of her dad and of her mum.
But also it's that longing and hoping for a different outcome that describes kind of being very watchful and really wanting to make sure that they weren't alone together. And that level of threat and distress that must have been going on at that time to then have all of that still outweigh the desire to kind of to emancipate, to say, actually, I'm not, I'm not having you in my life. We're not, we're not doing this and it's not okay. What happened. But, you know, I think, yeah, those desire, the desire to repair and reconnect and ultimately to be loved, that can be so very powerful. And I think, you know, the overarching question, that people have about the situation is, well, why did she stay? You know, she wasn't handcuffed,
she wasn't restrained. She was free to come and go, to go from where she was living, and then to come back when she was called. And I think, you know, this is where the nuance really is kind of apparent and there's, it's incredibly complex, isn't it? And people, you know, absolutely begin to think that that's their worth, but also when people are being paid for something, then that becomes a job, doesn't it? And when you've got a job, you can kind of have that sunk cost fallacy. Well, you know, at least I've got a job and I'm being paid. And if I've been doing it for this long, it will be hard to get a job and people will notice the gaps on my CV and they'll wonder where I've been and what I've been doing. We can almost invalidate ourselves really by staying in situations
might feel damaging. And I think there's also complex mechanisms at play here with with possible dissociation. So in order to do things that your mind doesn't want you to do, but you're being asked to do by someone with your body, then sometimes we'll dissociate from that, especially if you are being fed and clothed and looked after and paid recently well and kept in, you know, good standards, kind of luxury standards, living a luxury life going to desert islands and kind of meeting hugely influential people, that lifestyle can be hard to quit. And it does muddy the water, doesn't it? You know, especially if someone's been abused when they were younger, then we're not
comparing someone that's had a very stable, solid existence of being loved and adored. and being able to talk about things are challenging and having that be responded to, that was not her experience as a child or as an adolescent. And when you've been raised in an abusive situation, then your own unique sense of worth and value can be affected. So when someone is looking upon you favourably, telling you that you're a good girl,
that you're, you know, that you're beautiful, that you're doing things really well, that also can be really, really tricky to start saying no to. And of course, the very important point here is that her younger brother, whom she adored, had been threatened. So if she was going to tell anybody about what happened to her or what was happening to her, then, you know, bad things would happen. And when you do have someone that adores you in your family,
then, of course, that leverage over you is going to, hold really a great deal of weight indeed. I would love your thoughts on this. What have you thought to this episode? What's it evoked for you? Have you read Nobody's Girl? Are you intrigued to read it in future? I would love to know what you think of it.
If you like this style of diving into books that are kind of psychologically relevant, then please do take a moment to go over to YouTube if you're not already watching on YouTube and check out my psychology behind the story series. This is my first solo podcast episode for quite some times. It's really nice to connect with you in this way. If you enjoy hearing me talk about complex human emotions and processes, I think you might also really like my exclusive members-only content podcast, which is called Inner Work.
And you can dive into that as a free three-day trial on Apple. You can join directly from Captivate, and you can join on YouTube too. There's details in the show notes and please let me know if you've got any questions, if you've got any ideas for future topics for the podcast, I would love to receive them too. Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a master's in psychology of mental health. Marion recommended me the clinical psychologist collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a
into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others, but with myself too. Also, not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, growth, and the final result of will come as a byproduct. Marian, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem, and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.